gloria is here she is the author of mary
him making the case
for settling for mr good
enough the book is based on a survey
where men and women were asked if they
got 80
of everything they want in their ideal
mate would they be happy with that
and women said no that's settling and
men said 80 percent i'd be thrilled
that's a catch
and so 80 to the women you surveyed
is settling that's settling because you
know the question is
what actually makes us happy in
long-term romantic love
and you know that's the question that i
explore in the book and i'm a journalist
so i went out and i asked
neurobiologists about chemistry and i
asked behavioral economists about
demographics and i asked marital
researchers
what are women too picky about here
well i'll tell you i'll tell you men and
women were asked what would be a deal
breaker for going on a second date and
men named three things
they said she has to be cute enough she
doesn't have to look like angelina jolie
she just has to be cute enough
she has to be warm and kind and she has
to be interesting to talk to
those seem like really valid criteria
ding ding ding ding ding
pretty simple right okay reasonable
right the women came back with 300
things
that would rule out a guy for a second
date and we're talking about like
another two hours and maybe a free
dinner
and they wouldn't do it and there were
things like he wore a brown belt with
black shoes
or we were having a really good time and
i thought he was cute and he was
interesting but then
he went he did this austin powers
impression and i just can't get that out
of my mind and i can't go out with him
again
austin powers guy could be the love of
her life if he does these impressions on
the second date okay don't go on a third
but maybe he was just nervous
the guys who are bad first daters might
be great life partners you don't know
bars i ain't got nothing to say let me
just let her pray
she just she said she hey hey
you got nothing to say here let me make
the other argument you have to have a
list
lori you have to you just can't run
around dating any tom
dick or harry you you have to develop a
list
and you have to have you have to have
the right things on your list they have
to be the right things
um you know the character things the you
know do we
is he kind um do we have the same life
goals do we have the same values the
fundamentals do we enjoy each other how
do we communicate with each other
you know somebody said to me you know
this woman that i was really interested
in
wouldn't go out with me because i didn't
read the same books that she did but
she's
madly in love with this guy who reads
the same books but he doesn't call her
when he says he will
what are your thoughts i just ain't got
[ __ ] to say
i mean it's just that it's it's what i
see
it's what i see in in some of my my
girls friends
uh some of my friends some of my girls
friends
and whatever we sit down and we talk oh
yeah i got my dating pro man i'm like
yeah
girl sit down yeah but he did this and
he did that and then i'm like
girl you're gonna be alone for the rest
of your life like if you keep on going
like that
for little stuff you know there's people
that if you look at them
they don't go together right as a matter
of fact if you look at me and my wife we
don't technically
for what most people would look for we
do not go together
like i like loud ass music she doesn't
i like bass i like people she doesn't
i like motorcycles nope we don't watch
necessarily the same shows but raising a
family ain't about the shows you watch
it ain't about the motorcycles you watch
and anybody all
you know so you know what it's funny
because when people talk about
compatibility they talk about
oh we share the same hobby oh we like
the same shows but we can't talk that's
fine for when you're dating but when you
think about doing something
long-term your compatibility should not
basically yourself on that
should be a matter of values it should
be a matter of
a vision me and preach are
nothing alike in terms of personality
every on every point
on every point name them we are
polar opposites on everything
girls we like on what we drive on how we
eat
on what we eat on everything
yeah maybe music
and even then there's a bit of overlap
but really not but you know where we do
have compatibility it's values yup
me and preach both value integrity
me and preach both value work and
consistently mean preach both value
speaking our minds
right there's one thing i've never
questioned about you it's your integrity
you know if you ask me yo is this some
[ __ ] going on yeah we sit down we talk
about it we chop it up
right that's it if we think about it i'm
not
like mad that we're not friends i can't
even
see it because we're so not alike
no we're not but you know what though i
think when it comes to
a work of partnership it's perfect
in a way it's perfect in a way because
what we are saying
is important between the two of us to
have is what matters for this to work
it's the foundational aspects of this
it's not like we both like
dancing and all this it has nothing to
do with that
no is that when it comes down to the
difficult parts
i know i can count on your character
because we're both going to handle this
difficult situation probably similar
right and we have we have the same goal
as well the goal is the same the values
are the same
the personality polar opposites exactly
when we say people
should settle it doesn't mean settle
on ideas like foreign it means that
people are being picky about things that
are not important to what a longevity of
a marriage
or anything like that is right we say
settle it's settled for the super fluid
stuff
and people are not capable of doing that
you put all the same
oh my god he matches his like a brown a
black belt with brown shoes come
a brown belt and black shoes ain't gonna
raise a family
as a matter of fact maybe a brown belt
and black shoes
will raise a family but it doesn't help
anywhere else yeah yeah people bring
this all kinds of stuff that doesn't
even matter
no to the longevity well um
he's not the hottest guy so eventually
you guys are gonna stop being attractive
well you know what he's not the best in
bed
guess what most married people don't
have the wildest sex life for the most
part
no you can you can learn you get
you could learn together you could you
know but it's not as long as you got
your moment it's like like
when you whenever we we took that that
life on instagram and that guy was like
i think i'm boring
no maybe you're just not complicated
that's not your thing
we don't have hobbies we don't do
anything are you good
yeah then you good then those are just
bonuses those are just bonuses that if
you have that
great but they're not necessary those
are privileges those are luxuries
yeah but he doesn't like lil yachty like
i like lil yachty
who gives a so so and and we bring this
up or people like well
i'd rather i'd rather be alone than be
in a toxic relationship
let's be clear about something a lot of
people who are in quote unquote
toxic relationships i question how you
marry somebody who is unbelievably toxic
did you not know who this person was
when you lived with them did you not who
know who this person was
when you were starting to get with them
when you guys were making your vows did
you not know this person what changed
after you got married and what you come
to realize is that it's not generally
relationships that are toxic it's not
marriages that are toxic it's the
expectations going in
people find out that the quote unquote
uh
labor that you have to put in is not fun
it's not roses it's not the wedding
ceremony
me as a woman i don't think that i was
necessarily prepared or in the mindset
to know that it's almost like
once you get into it then you're like oh
shoot like this is what i'm to have to
keep up with
us speaking as 36 year old people know
that now your wedding is one day
yup your marriage is the rest and the
marriage is labor the wedding is that
one day
i when the cake is cut
the dress is worn and the flowers
are faded you have marriage and now you
have to work on that
that day is gone yep you have to work
it's work it's work don't sit there and
think that it's not working everything
is easy you got to work
you got to be able to you have to be
willing to put the work
that and that's the thing that's a lot
when you stop putting the
stop putting the effort that's when it's
just like yeah
if two people come in and say they're
gonna put in the effort they're gonna
put in the labor
right and they're not disillusioned
about what i think one of the biggest
disservice that we have in our society
today
is that married people and our parents
generation didn't give us a very honest
look at what marriage is supposed to
look like
they let the media fill those ideas in
for us
because often times their parents were
either divorced or more concerned with
their own interest in their own
well-being
right so the media filled in our ideas
of what a marriage is supposed to look
like
because most of us a lot of us didn't
grow up with that example in our lives
that's why people who come from married
households where things were relatively
healthy
are far more likely to be married than
people who didn't right
yeah because their example is based off
of something firm they saw their parents
so if you take people from third world
countries right most
folks from like south asia are going to
end up married and stay made for most of
their life
why because of what they saw when they
were growing up they had a real look at
what it was supposed to look like
you know what i'm saying yes everyone
else when i talk to people about
marriages and
and what like a lifelong commitment
supposed to look like they talk about
love and they talk about you know
happiness and all these other things and
i'm like
but do you understand that's just a
byproduct or reward of something
do you know that's a byproduct of of of
duty of responsibility
of labor do you not understand like
that's the things you should be thinking
about
not the reward you should be thinking
about the process you know they're
talking about like there's
responsibilities like a duty within like
uh marriage to to to sex and all this
stuff with another
black couple yeah i remember yeah like
me at 24 i didn't know what a marriage
entailed i didn't know what it would be
like to raise kids
i didn't know what like giving birth how
it would affect my body all these things
and it makes you realize most people
are never given these real examples and
it's they don't
know they don't think about that and
it's not talked about no it's not talked
about they don't know about it they just
oh yeah no you know what i'm gonna go
into this and it's all flowers and
everything and stuff especially that's
25. you know it's a status you like the
status hey i'm
married yes i got a husband i got a
whole ring
you should have put a ring on it if you
like it or whatever the hell she thinks
yeah it's the status and at 2425 it
really sounds good but it's much more
than the status
it's more than that it's work you got to
work you got to be able to be willing to
work
and you have to know that a lot of
things change it's not going to say like
that the whole time you know
women are usually the ones who leave the
marriages sort of like the men are happy
in their marriages and women don't
realize that
they're the ones who are often
dissatisfied and when this researcher
that i spoke to looked at people who
were getting divorced
it turned out that the women rated their
marriages as you know
seven not not like three or four as
seven
they would say things like i love him
but i'm not in love with him anymore
and the men were devastated because they
thought the marriage was just fine
right because they're they're not asking
for as much right well
they have high expectations but they're
realistic about well that's right
yes i think the individual has lost
sight of what it means to be part of a
collective
and has lost the ability to understand
that like sometimes
my little wants i have to take a
backseat
because i'm striving for something
bigger you know like preach if i was
trying to stay
axed and fixated on everything i wanted
out of my work life
you and i would never be working
together and vice versa
vice versa i got my advices you know
what i'm saying
i got my vices but you sometimes have to
put your wants on the back burner
because you guys
as a collective as a unit are striving
for something bigger i just know this
that
i'm more powerful with other people i
know that you know what i mean on my
on my flag is written false which the
union is our power and that's what it is
so
i'm ready to that you know what
keep game that word settling it has such
a bad rap
it's people whenever the when you hear
settling
you know what they hear they hear give
up
when they say no you didn't you should
settle you said oh i gave up
that's what they hear in the back of
their head that's what they hear
when you say to someone oh yeah you're
settling down i didn't settle
me nev they hear you gave up
it has a bad rap in the in the in the
connotation of people's brain
and the way the words work settling down
has a bad bad rap so whenever you say
you should settle down no i'm never
going to give up that's what they hear
and that's what it is that's the problem
is the perception that they have of what
settling is
settling is just a thing it's not a good
thing it's not a bad thing it's a thing
you know
okay and then after that how you settle
and the context which is very important
is going to determine
whether it's good or bad but it's not
inherently good or bad it's just a thing
but people you say settle automatical
bad you gave up and i think people have
this idea that if they're going to
settle they're going to be inherently
unhappy it's like
no yeah because they gave up you know
some of the greatest things in life come
from compromise
some of the greatest things in life
things that you have to say you know
what i'm gonna just swallow my pride
let me see where this thing goes i'm
gonna put in the work and you come out
on the other end and it gives you
benefits and rewards that you never
could have had otherwise
without having to sacrifice some things
you know maybe my partner
isn't the best looking partner i could
have had but guess what when i come home
at night
this person holds me down when i'm doing
successful thing they
always there yeah do you think what i'm
saying
it's okay it's okay the
the best things in my life has always
come from settling in compromise
it's not for me i will never you gotta
compromise that doesn't mean you
compromise on
everything but on the things that are
really not that important if you're
being honest with yourself
which are just linked to your ego at
some point you have to be honest like
why am i holding on to this thing it's
not even necessary but i'm pretending
and treating it like it is
and it's holding me back i will not
work at a job
that doesn't have the prestige
but it pays better than the job that has
the prestige yeah i won't work there
all right then then don't but don't
you know maybe you can't brag about it
to your friends like your doctor friend
can't but guess what me that job would
have been happier gave you more
flexibility
more autonomy more juices over what you
wanted to do but you won't do that
because of your
ego is that something to be respected to
be revered
you know one thing i loved about being
where i'm from is like
you settle all the time because it's a
survival thing you can't afford to have
this
i got my standards in this like but you
got food to put on the table for people
you feel what i'm saying you better
marry this person they may not be the
best looking but they come from a good
family
okay and they and they got their
priorities set and they will they will
get you through
and your family through whatever you got
to do you know what i mean that's right
and they stay married
they stay married my daddy
my daddy always told me this he wanted
he came here
and he went to school and stuff and he
always wanted to work in the laboratory
he wanted to be able to make tests and
stuff like that
but my sister was underway yeah
so he became a nurse don't sit on your
dreams
listen he had a kid coming
and the second one and the second one
was a fat one
that's right and was eating all he
needed to put
food on the table he settled but he's
got what he's got now
he's good now you see you you see you
seen my dad
and if i look at him today i'm like i
hope i get to be like him when i'm older
i'm not even i'm not your friend i see
your dad sometimes but i'm like
i want that to be me
chilling chillin
yo genuinely bro very big inspiration
i'm a big fan
i remember when i was looking at him in
haiti and just watching him enjoy the
little things and i'm like
this man's figured it out yeah yeah
he had to sacrifice yeah maybe he didn't
love all of his choices
but when you look at where he's at you
know in the latter stage of his life you
can tell he's like i'm good with the
choices i made
and it was good for the people around me
yeah my dad my dad likes you too
actually
he really hey come on
you invited to the house anytime you
want because
i was like yeah yeah yeah okay and
sometimes he's reassured he's like okay
oh you're gonna be with abba all right
you yeah you guys are good
you guys good he knows he knows anything
and he's seen what we've accomplished
and [ __ ] like that so
yeah my i think is there's reciprocity
here where my dad is like no no all
right
let's do let's do the cool dude you're a
cool dude yeah my mom just wants to
you're here so so she wants to know like
is he is this is that right now he's
chilling don't even worry about that
abba is chilling he's
he's not me mom chill yeah
yeah and and and there's something to be
admired there there's something to be
admired there to
the priority like gum that they put on
on the group in the family unit like the
idea of like
doing things for the greater group like
there's something i really
appreciate about that because i think
you know grown up in the west it's
always about the individual
what are your thoughts what are my needs
i really want a child
what does that mean to have a child to
bring in this world it's just something
i feel is good
you will never hear them talk about
legacy you never have to talk about like
generational wealth you never know about
like family traditions
none of that everything is about me
and there's a certain level of
selfishness that comes in which i think
permeates
to marriages and that's why i think we
fail so often because we're like
what i want and even i've fallen guilty
to that
my own decisions in some of my
absolutely and and i catch myself and
i'm like whoa
uh but i think through putting like
like having to humble myself in certain
circumstances i've realized
there's something bigger than me and
when i invest in it it's
far more rewarding than anything i could
have done for just myself uniquely
definitely and and that's and that's the
thing like
people think that by preaching like that
we we put ourselves in a stance
where we think we're better than y'all
whatever we're not no
no we [ __ ] up
we [ __ ] up and if we say stuff like that
right now and if we're both to film like
that
it's because we had to learn sometimes
from the hard way we've been like that
we recognize what we say
it's not like yeah you know look at them
these peasants no
we recognize these behaviors in us as
well
and me and we're constantly learning i
mean i've learned so much about you
you know like i'll say this and i say
this very comfortably like in terms of
like learning about relationships and
friendships like
you've been one of the biggest sources
of information and
uh knowledge in that realm but you know
that takes a certain level of humbleness
and to like be like
oh man this perspective okay there's
something that he's doing that i'm not
that
i can take away from because i see how
it's rewarded his life and the people
around him
and it's helped me to be better in my
relationships
better my friendships better with people
around me
and i think knowing that it's like oh i
get to undo a lot of the societal
conditioning that i've had
that's made me inherently selfish in
some ways to bring it back to the topic
man
i i did this yeah i think
settling has such a negative connotation
but i think if people huddle build
themselves they realize they can grow so
much
from from just accepting less
and then realizing there's so much more
to pull from it yeah
definitely you know except less
initially to get
more later you know
and um
and and i think if people don't learn
that lesson if they don't make that
investment in their lifetime
they're going to be missing out on one
of the best lessons in life
that sometimes you just gotta take
what's given to you and work with it
yeah and sometimes you can make some
that's far exceeding anything you could
have envisioned for yourself
you know and it's not because your
partner was more amazing than you
imagine or anything that
but the labor that you put in helped you
craft something from yourself that you
couldn't have imagined so
um i would just tell people to think
about that and understand that these
ideas
don't have to be negative they've just
constantly told you that they
are all right so that would be the main
thing that i'll take away from this
absolutely that's pretty much it we want
to hear what you guys think in the
comments below
let us know your thoughts we want to
hear from you guys um that's right
[Music]
oh